welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in jorge masavidal and daniel cormier
have gotten into a war of words recently
due to cormier's comments on his show dc
and rc after mozvidal hinted at fighting
leon edwards for his newly acquired
welterweight title daniel cormier
advised edwards to ignore mosbidal
cormier's stance came from the fact that
when mozville was at his highest he
attacked edwards backstage but never
took care of business with him in the
octagon mosvidal fired back at cormier
with a lengthy tweet guess you're still
butthurt since i didn't do the interview
you requested on your week youtube
channel during my fight week i know you
needed my name to produce some sort of
view since ariel went solo and you
became a has been just make sure when
dana calls and tells you to promote the
biggest fight the current champ can make
in the division which is me wear your
best suit from dxl and make sure you do
as you're told like a good boy maybe
you'll get a treat from your master
hashtag reason people watch on mute
fake life coach hashtag broke advice
cormier responded to mozvidal with a
tweet of his own and suggested that
masvidal's manager malkikawa was
tweeting on behalf of his client jorge
you've always been the man malkie stay
off his page i stand by what i said you
don't get unlimited title fights malkie
beat dorino get to one of three in the
last four and maybe get a title shot see
malki now you got me disrespecting my
friend jorge leon edwards head kick ko
of kamara usman at ufc 278 shook up the
ufc pound-for-pound rankings usman lost
not only his welterweight title but also
his position atop the ufc's
pound-for-pound rankings the ufc
released their updated rankings where
usman dropped to the number 4 spot leon
edwards victory also propelled him into
the rankings for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at dana white's contender series post
fight press conference white filled in
reporters on what was discussed during
his most recent conversation with kamara
usman the biggest takeaway from white
was that kamaru feels relieved from a
great burden of pressure we talk teasing
great spirits obviously he wants the
rematch bad but he said i can't tell you
the weight that's been lifted off of me
there's a lot of pressure that goes
along with the run that he was on and
tying and breaking anderson's record all
that stuff there's a lot of pressure so
he's looking forward to the rematch when
asked about how leon edwards felt about
a rematch with usman white revealed the
champ is ready to go he's down he's
ready to defend he's ready to take on
whatever it is he's going on a whirlwind
media tour when he goes home a lot of
stuff changes when you get that built so
his whole world is about to change in
the next few weeks but he is ready for
it white then answered questions on two
of the biggest names in the welterweight
division whose fight status has been up
in the air for several months according
to white he's looking at booking fights
for coley covington very soon and is
intrigued of a match-up between jorge
mosvidal and gilbert burns video
courtesy of the mack life
last one for me uh gilbert burns was
saying that
he he was about to fight mars without
jorge masvidal was in the plan
was
does it make sense for you gilbert burn
burns against jorge masvidal
maybe december maybe next year
yeah i like it
you like it
i love this [ __ ]
then i'll do it
thank you yep thank you
just one more day another world's way
have you guys spoken to colby and can he
fight with the legal stuff he's got
going on or is he going to be gone for a
while do you know what's up colby yeah
yeah no colby wants to fight colby wants
to fight he's ready to fight and we're
making plans for him here soon awesome
thank you yeah former ufc middleweight
champion luke rockhold has officially
retired from the ufc after his decision
lost apollo costa at ufc 278 an
emotional rock hold told joe rogan that
he had just fought his last fight now
according to mmafighting.com's damon
martin the retirement is official in a
tweet martin shared the news saying luke
rockhold has officially notified the ufc
of his retirement per officials here's
to luke on an incredible career as both
a ufc and strikeforce champion and
somebody who was never afraid to speak
his mind hashtag ufc rockhold leaves his
mma career with a 16-6 record and as a
former middleweight champion in both the
ufc and strikeforce this friday one
championship will be hosting their first
event streamed by amazon prime video one
on prime video one marias vs johnson two
the card will also feature one flyweight
muay thai champion rod tang jitmon who
will be facing saabas michael in the
semi-finals of the one flyweight muay
thai world grand prix rod tang who was
undefeated in muay thai under the one
promotion recently spoke about why the
grand prix is so important to him the
world grand prix championship means so
much to me i now have the main belt for
muay thai and everyone is looking to
take it from me that's why i decided to
join this grand prix and try to be the
champion if i get the win no one in this
rank can challenge me because then i'd
have my main belt and the world grand
prix built raw tang also threw some
shade at his opponent on instagram
making it clear he is headed into this
fight with full confidence savas can't
beat me he wouldn't be able to beat me
as a kid tune in on one on prime video
one the main card for one on prime video
one will begin streaming friday august
26th at 10 pm eastern only on amazon
prime video
[Applause]
beard in the muay thai world
for 21 ties he's beaten 18 of them
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action